what up space fam goes in here from
anime Opera and I'm back at it again
with another one piece video and this
time we will be exploring Luffy's power
and why exactly everyone is so scared of
our joyful protagonist so make sure to
stay tuned for that if you do enjoy
these one piece videos I want to keep
them coming you know what to do Channel
parking with it and smash that like
button with no mercy remember smashing
that like button is pirate king energy
and passing is scared Orochi energy so
Choose Wisely if you haven't make this
the video subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next video to drop feel
free to check out my huge and growing
one piece playlist that includes videos
on the yonko Warlords mythical zones and
much more link to that is in the
description and now without further Ado
let's jump into It spoilers and all
recently during chapter 1042 of the One
Piece manga a cp0 agent received a
message the five Elders have issued an
edict he was surprised about it coming
directly from the five Elders it must be
important if they issue this directly
then the message goes on eliminate Straw
Hat Luffy at once end quote at first our
cp0 agent actually protests saying what
do you mean straw hat is fighting kaido
right now you want me to interfere with
kaido's battle that's impossible The
Voice responds it's a world-class battle
which is why it's so dangerous these
orders are meant to prevent the worst
case scenario you understand even easel
overhears this thinking what is it about
this crew that the five Elders would
want to get rid of Luffy so badly they'd
even interrupt kaido's fight with one of
their best the cp0 agent goes on to
interrupt the fight and as a result a
helpless and exhausted Luffy takes the
full brunt of kaido's attack at
point-blank range ironically kaido is
crushed partly because he wanted a fair
fight and beyond that it brings back bad
memories of when his fight with Odin was
interrupted a memory that clearly still
haunts him to this day just as he
handled kurozumi Higurashi for
interrupting his fight with Odin he
similarly appears to finish off the
already injured cp0 agent for
interrupting this fight with Luffy thus
the five Elders were willing to lose one
of their best cp0 agents and anger kaido
the same time the man called the world's
strongest creature just so they could
kill Luffy and avoid a potential worst
case scenario it's just crazy to think
about but soon enough it appears that
what they so feared begins to happen
anyways the proclaimed dead Luffy comes
back to life but this time he comes back
with an awakened fruit gear 5 and as the
joy boy of the new era we jump back to
the five Elders talking and they think
about how they just lost an elite agent
and made kaido Angry one says and I
quote what if I told you that there was
a potential future that would make us
beg for this outcome it is always better
to eliminate dangerous variables end
quote we're further told in every era
the world government has attempted to
recover the gum gum fruit and not once
has it succeeded for 800 years it is as
though the devil fruit is trying to
escape our grasp and it very well might
Zone fruits contain a will of their own
and this particular fruit has the name
of a God the other name of the gum gum
fruit is the Zone type human human fruit
mythical model Nika possessing a body
with properties of rubber and fighting
in whatever way he fancies he brings
smiles to the faces of the people the
warrior of Liberation also known as Nika
the sun god Awakening brings his rubber
body greater physical strength and
freedom it is said in all the world
there is no power more ridiculous end
quote and notably not one but two
exclamation marks are used after the
word ridiculous so this is what they've
been trying to avoid Luffy seemingly
possesses the single most Wanted fruit
that even the world government hasn't
been able to get and keep despite all of
their power and resources it was such a
big deal that they changed its name and
wanted to completely erase its history
however despite all their effort Luffy
actually awakened the Nika fruit and
gained Godly Powers that's why I
somewhat jokingly said that Luffy
accidentally passed the goal of becoming
the pirate king and became a pirate God
to use his own words Luffy reached the
peak of this most special and arguably
overpowered of fruits now yes the exact
words were the most ridiculous fruit but
when you think of how much the
government feared it then it's not a
stretch pun intended to say that it is
the most special of fruits even during
who's whose fight against jinbei who's
who mentioned sun god Nika a figure
slaves would pray to in the long distant
past he was a legendary Warrior they
believed would one day free them he'd
bring smiles to their faces and deliver
them from suffering whose who said that
he actually clung to that strange legend
himself that prison guard who told him
about the story of Nika disappeared Days
Later whose who felt he was in danger
too so he risked it all to escape he
asks jimbei is it deadly to even know
about the legend that's how crazy scared
the world government is of the awakened
fruit that even knowing the legend of
Nika is grounds for making people
disappear but that's not the only take
away from the story that who's who tells
Nika gave people even who's who himself
hope he was a figure who United people
under him even people as unlike Luffy as
who's who found solace in the legend
Nika kept people's will from being
broken and promised Freedom From Slavery
and by extension from the oppressing
forces of the world government and the
celestial dragons the world government
even feared the legend so it makes sense
that the thought of having a
ridiculously powerful Flesh and Blood
sun god Nika scared them to no end not
only do they probably fear the godly
power and its potential but they feared
that this figure will motivate the
oppressed around the world to stand up
and seek their freedom from the world
government knowing that if they take the
first step Nika will probably Aid them
in their Endeavor just like he aided
many others this will lead to a domino
effect that will very quickly become an
existential threat to the very existence
of the world government thus Luffy
physically and perhaps more importantly
symbolically poses a threat to the
continued existence of the world
government and the current world order
they fear nothing more than him as sun
god bringing a new dawn of freedom and
then we come to Luffy's actual use of
gear 5 and his fruit Awakening he seems
to be able to break all the rules he
said says this is the Pinnacle of what
he can do he is able to grab Dragon form
kaido like a toy snake and pull him up
back to the roof he slams him into the
ground over and over again we've spoken
of the tune world powers on this channel
where it seems like Luffy can use
cartoon logic to bend reality for
himself others and the environment
around him we were told that with this
Awakening the user can fight in any way
he fancies but I did not expect that
Luffy would be quite this free to do
anything with his new powers we see him
rubberize the ground and pull it up in
order to send kaido's blast breath back
at him we see Luffy blow himself up like
a balloon inside kaido's body and while
still inside even stick his hands
through kaido's eyeballs so he can grab
the dragon's nose he takes on a giant
Godlike form that makes it appear like
he Towers over kaido's giant dragon form
in a panel and then he even uses kaido
as a skipping rope he can fly by running
through the air he can re-enter this
all-white gear 5 form after it drains
him his rubber properties have gotten so
Advanced that his face will just wrap
around stuff like Spike clubs when they
hit him he can even rubberize the ground
under him along with himself to dampen
the effects of attacks he's seen
punching kaido through the face even
don't ask me how that works I have no
idea even kaido says that Awakening is
what happens when your mind and body
catch up to their powers and that
Luffy's are certainly some ridiculous
Powers most recently we saw Luffy with a
lightning bolt in his hand making him
look like a lightning god at this point
there is seemingly very little if
anything he can't do he seems to be the
epitome of the quote if you can dream it
you can achieve it and he's been
dominating kaido with these new powers
the man dubbed the strongest creature in
the world despite the fact that I'm sure
we've only seen the top of the iceberg
that is Luffy's new potential he's
already been doing crazy good against
kaido who among the living yonko has the
highest Bounty at 4.6 billion berries
I'm not saying that kaido won't still
put up a fight but it seems clear at
this point that Luffy will win and that
furthermore this 19 year old's rate of
growth makes kaido looked like a snail
rather than a dragon once this fight is
finished there's little doubt in my mind
that Luffy will have the highest Bounty
ever even surpassing pirate king Goldie
Rogers own Bounty of 5 billion 564
million 800 000 berries not only will he
have beaten kaido the yonko with the
highest Bounty he'd also be the fully
realized worst case scenario that the
world government feared so much not to
mention all of the other connections
Luffy has including to Monkey D Dragon
the world's worst criminal into Shanks
the man with enough suede to stop kaido
from attacking Whitebeard to stop the
Paramount war and to meet with the five
Elders when he feels like it whether he
consciously knows it or not Luffy wants
the same thing as Dragon Liberation so
it's clear that his father is the kind
of guy to have the warrior of
liberations back then there's just basic
stuff like Luffy being a d-clan member
and a conquerors hockey user both of
which make him all the more dangerous
and of course there's a famous
observation that mihawk made that it's
not Luffy's powers or techniques Luffy
possesses some quality that makes people
want to help him and in these Waters
mihawk called that the most formidable
power of all combine Luffy's ability to
connect people with sun god dika's
ability to even reach someone like who's
who and you start to realize why this is
such a dangerous ability United We Stand
and divided we fall it's a truth known
by the world government and Luffy
especially as the sun god is so scary
because he can unite people behind him
even potentially people on the world
government's own side and there's
nothing more dangerous than that when
trying to maintain control over so many
diverse groups and peoples so there it
is why everyone is scared of Luffy yeah
he's a sun god and can bend reality
itself he's become ridiculously strong
and his rate of growth is beyond belief
when compared to even other Legends in
the world which is enough to scare most
people but it goes beyond that
especially for the world government him
naturally having the ability to unite
people behind him and then him also
being the realized sun god Nika whose
Legend alone could reach someone like
who's who means that he is the greatest
threat to the world government since the
world government needs people to be
divided if they wish to successfully
keep them down and then there are the
insane facts that Luffy has connections
to Monkey D Dragon the leader of the
revolutionaries and the shanks and you
can see how this man is a bigger threat
to the world government than gold D
Roger and how they must give him a
bigger Bounty even after adjusting for
inflation I mean physically alone we
were told that kaido is the strongest
creature and that if it's a one-on-one
battle kaido will win and yet we pretty
much know by now that Luffy will beat
him and to boot that insane power
doesn't belong to a drunk doing his own
thing and somewhat even working with the
world government rather Luffy is
uncontrollable and wants Liberation AKA
freedom for himself and others we've
seen how uncontrollable and
uncompromising Luffy is when he punched
the Celestial Dragon thus in terms of
Threat Level there's no doubt in my mind
that he'll get the highest Bounty we've
seen after this war Zoro will even have
a higher Bounty than Luffy's current
Bounty at 1.5 billion berries no doubt
and if the government was so panicked to
stop the worst case scenario before it
was even certain it would happen there's
little doubt that they'll go hard at
Luffy after this war is done they may
even be desperate enough to work with
Blackbeard to get it done but that is it
for this one if you did enjoy it and
want to keep the one piece videos coming
you know what to do Channel pirate king
within and smash that like button with
no mercy remember smashing is pirate
king energy and passing is scared Orochi
energy so Choose Wisely if you haven't
make this the video subscribe and hit
that notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you won't miss future
one piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next video to drop feel
free to check out my huge and growing
one piece playlist that includes videos
on the yonko Warlords mythical zones and
much more link to that is in the
description and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys